elle est expirée monsieur ah voyons vous
savez combien de fois je suis entré
sortie d'ici avec ça excusez-moi
qu'est-ce qui cloche avec ma carte
sortez du véhicule monsieur vous voulez
que chaque véhicule alors il est du
bataillon de ranger
le bataillon de ranger
je me suis cassé le cul pour que mon
esprit et mon corps retrouve un bon
équilibre je veux reprendre du service
messieurs vous voulez reprendre du
service vous pouvez le sergent Rodriguez
est une légende funérailles familiale
dimanche près de Magalas et il veut son
chien funérailles vous faites ça et vous
reprenez du service vos collabore avec
personne elle est gentille une minute et
ensuite elle envoie trois gars l'urgence
alors le chien tous les deux on va faire
un petit voyage en voiture tranquille
pourquoi vous avez peur elle est pas si
terrible
tu peux me dire c'est quoi ton problème
et si tu baissé ton agressivité d'un
cran
[Musique]
non terriens comment mais qu'est-ce qui
t'est arrivé c'était une légende d'abord
[Musique]
tu es très gentil
comment ça elle mange dans votre main je
lui parle c'est tout regardez elle est
tellement mignonne et tellement gentil
si tu fais rien d'autre de cinglé durant
ce voyage on pourrait peut-être s'amuser
tu es d'accord
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est toi bonne fille il lui
fait des câlins maintenant Lulu fait les
meilleurs câlins t'as jamais fait de
câlins
alors tu me dis que nous qui était aussi
perturbé que Lulu avant j'ai dû le faire
travailler tous les jours pendant 6 mois
quand il a arrêté de lutter j'ai compris
que je pouvais arrêter de lutter moi
aussi
ça va ça va c'est rien que l'orage
regardez ça
elle n'a jamais dormi dans un bon lit
auparavant à vouloir un grand matelas
douillet j'espère que vous auriez une
chambre pour moi et ma petite fille
est-ce que c'est une médaille pour les
blessés
merci pour votre dévouement
vous n'avez jamais vu ce chien démontré
un comportement agressif auparavant
jamais elle aime tout le monde
[Musique]
je peux voir
des définitivement pas la fille avec qui
je pensais prendre un bain je prendrai
ce que je peux avoir à ce stade
[Musique]